hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my flash episode 21 video careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen it yet
Barry Allen what a lame name Bart sounds
so much cooler are you sure my name
isn't Bart I hope all you Young Justice
fans appreciate them making an episode
of the flash just for you so there's a
new round of the flash ring giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
but there was a couple important things
going on in this episode that were hat
tips for a big twist that I think are
going to be coming in the finale I have
a couple predictions and I think they're
even seeding ideas and concepts for
season 4 and Clifford DeVoe the thinker
who has a lot of mind control memory
based powers so I'll explain that as we
go through top 10 WTF but starting with
number 10 the really important stuff is
thats avatar explains his backstory so
what he says is that he's a time remnant
created by this version of future Barrie
two fights avatar
he created a couple time remnant
saboteur killed them all
with the exception of one so that that
one could live to become saboteur the
reason he explains he became saboteur is
that the rest of team flash shunned him
because he wasn't the real Barry Allen
so they pushed him away he started
resenting everything in the pages got
too much and suddenly he got the bright
idea that God doesn't feel pain so I'll
become the god of speed so that's how
avatar was born he then went back in
time and used the philosopher's stone
way back in the past to create the midst
of sabotage
he jumped through the time line
collecting acolytes building the myth of
sabotage that's how Jay Garrick heard
about it and told him very even says
what happens to you if I kill myself and
he says well that's the thing about time
travel Eddie killed himself but yet
you've our Thawne lived to come back
still so it's just a way for the flash
TV show to let you know that you know
somebody who time travels a lot has a
lot of different ways to come back which
is where we get to reverse flashed up he
hasn't come back yet but there are a
number of different ways this avatar
explainer howl like Eddie killed himself
that he's still around because he time
travels a lot i time travels a lot so
even if you kill yourself that might not
get rid of me so we'll talk more about
reverse flash in a little while but
number 9s avatar versus Barry round one
it's so cool that his suit
as an autopilot function that's the
thing my suit is way cooler than yours
so lot of special effects watching him a
run and jump into the suit it's sort of
a reverse version of the flash ring the
blast shooted jex from the ring then he
jumps into it this time the suit opens
up and he jumps into it so I know you're
all wondering it's kind of expensive for
them to do those special effects so I
don't know if they would do the flash
ring every single time but we're so
close we're going to be in season for
next year I think that that's going to
be the season where we see Barry use the
flash ring for the first time the number
8 team flash zaps Barry's memory and
they sort of walk through the logic of
sabotage I hate spin-offs Cisco makes
the Star Trek reference though it's like
evil Kirk he gets separated by the
transporter HR says they have Voyager on
their planet and Cisco's like I hate
spin-offs but the funny thing about this
is the metaphor works force avatar -
because saboteur is literally a spin-off
of Barry that's what a time remnant is
number 7 trial of the flash so if you
don't remember the trial of the flash
I'm using that for comedy but the comic
book story is something vastly different
about him being tried for the murder of
the reverse-flash this time they use it
for comedy the heat monger ends up
getting away because it doesn't work I
mean it was a lot of funny moments cisco
has to like help give him a boost of
self-esteem it's okay I think your name
is cool but he's another heat based
villain he's not from the comics there's
no heat monger in the flash comics
probably my favorite thing about all
this comedy with the memory though is
the Bart Allen stuff he even referred to
himself as Bart's it feels like oh thank
you nice to meet you Bart even Wally is
totally on board with calling Barry Bart
so everybody on every flash video that I
ever post especially the back half of
the season because we're getting closer
and closer to season 4 do you think that
we're going to see Bart Allen on the TV
show and if they'd only said Bart one
time in this episode I'd say you know
man whatever but they said it so many
times that it's like oh yeah we are
definitely going to do Bart Allen
eventually maybe not season 4 maybe not
season 5 but that's the writers beating
you in the face with Bart Allen being a
big character in the flash comics and
him coming around if you're not familiar
with who Bart Allen is he's the grandson
of Barry and iris he was sent from the
future to come back in time he was
introduced in the comics to sort of be
like a really young character because
Wally West used to be kid flash but then
Barry Allen died he became the main
version of the flash he was an adult so
they wanted a kid version of the flash
the new kid flash became impulse who was
Bart Allen what I think might happen in
the future is wild prediction if they
decide to include the Titans TV show in
the CW universe somehow even though it's
going to be on a different streaming
service
they'll send Wally West Kid Flash to go
be the flash of that TV show because
Wally was a part of the Teen Titans he
was also a big Titans character you have
to have a version of the flash on the
team so that'll leave the door open for
another version of the flash to get
introduced because they won't have Wally
around every single week so you get to
start laying your bets right now we
won't hear about that Titans show for a
while but we'll talk about it this
summer
they'll be big comic-con panel where
they hype it up Geoff Johns has been
hyping it up already but number six
killer frost comes to bargain Dormammu
I've come to bargain she wants avatar to
get his memories back so that they can
continue with their plans to become gods
so they need Barry to get his memories
back in by consequence also get Kid
Flash's powers back as well if you're
wondering why Kid Flash lost his powers
it's because Barry loses his memory in
sabot R is a future version of Barry
so Savitt R forgets who he is forgets
that he has powers and because he keeps
going backwards and forwards is that
mobius strip everything that happens
along his timeline starts to collapse
meaning that he never gave Wally West's
powers to begin with during flashpoint
so that is how Wally loses his powers
and that's where iris starts to get the
idea hey Barry super happy and we dealt
with Savitt R so would it be such a bad
thing if Barry never got his powers back
he'd still be very happy and they were
very clearly falling in love again even
though Barry didn't totally remember who
she was they had all that chemistry when
they're in the copy he made all the
funny jokes about being awkward in high
school so it's almost like iris would
still get to be happy with Barry but the
city would lose its flash and Wally
wouldn't have powers either so there'd
be zero flashes to stop any real
supervillains but she has a really
important line where she says maybe the
city doesn't need the flash so I feel
like that's a big hat tip for the twist
in the finale big red flashing warning
sign yes the city definitely needs the
flash that's the whole basis for the
flash comics villains have super
powers you need superheroes with powers
to take them down but that raises a lot
of interesting questions
if Barry collapses sabotage timeline and
that takes Wally's powers away will
Barry going into the Speed Force at the
end of the season deprive the city of
any version of the flash like this big
banner here flash vanishes in crisis
will this be something tied to Barry
going into the Speed Force just
something to think about is you're
making your theories for the finale in
the beginning of season four but there
were so many really good small details
they included in this especially Cisco
speech that invoked Ronnie and helped
remember Caitlin remember who she is
so the big twist there she's riding in
the elevator is that she kind of does
remember so even though she is still
killer frost her eyes sort of go back
into Caitlin mode letting you know that
she's not completely gone you belong
here you're our friend so it's like a
reverse version of what happened to the
future Barry that ended up becoming
Savitt are the team pushed him away
because he wasn't the real Barry but our
team flash is trying to keep Caitlin
close but number four Traci brand and HR
with the Speed bazooka so there's a
whole lot of stuff that they're setting
up really fast
they're very clearly pushing this
relationship and their chemistry is so
strong and intense do you not feel like
HR is doomed to die at the end of the
season like that's the reason why
they're rushing this relationship so
quickly otherwise what would they be
building towards I mean it's not like
they're going to end everything will be
happy they'll write off into the sunset
that's not how things end on the flash
each season finale of the flash ends
with a big villain takedown in an
equally big disaster in heartbreak so
you lose Ronnie in the season 1 finale
you lose Barry's dad at the end of
season 2 into season 3 somebody's going
to die from Team flash and it seems like
it's going to be HR now but Tom Cavanagh
is still a series regular on the TV show
so that doesn't mean the Tom Cavanagh
would be leaving the show it'd just be
like another version of Harrison wells
would show up next year but number three
they jumpstart Barry's memories they
shock him and iris has to talk him
through all of his tragedy get him to
remember that so that he can access the
other parts of his brain that help him
be the flash they did a really good job
of weaving the big theme of the episode
in that Barry needs all of his pain all
these things that have
variants make me who I am today the bad
stuff in the good stuff
for every bad memory there's a good
memory attached to it as well so the
night that he lost his mother is the
night that he met iris the other really
important part of this is in telling you
who the Barry Allen character is
fundamentally because before he got his
memories back he's still rushing to help
he said that doesn't matter if people
are going to die I need to save him it
doesn't matter if I know how my powers
work I have to do something to help so
it's their way of showing you that Barry
was a hero even before he got his
superpowers that's just who he is he's
always going to rush in to try and help
people but it was a great twist as he
remembers Wally also remembers and runs
in mid-fight as they take the fire down
simultaneously saboteur gets his
memories back I remember and is
back on so a lot of great details like
the Alexander Hambleton memories that
Barry had I loved the lie that iris told
to you were the happiest little boy the
first time we met this will be a fun
episode to re-watch they even make a
joke about why their apartment is so big
Wow how do we afford this everybody's
always been wondering that they did a
lot of really good shots at themselves
but number one they have to steal an
alien power source from it looks like
Argos because that's where king shark is
to power the speed bazooka they have to
power the weapon with more power than
you could pull out of the Sun it is a
really cool excuse for them to do a big
heist episode which will bring back
Captain Cold so what I'll do is there's
a lot of footage from this in the
trailer that I posted on Monday so I'll
link that at the end just so you get a
better context but I will do a trailer
video tomorrow we'll explain a little
bit more about what's going on but next
week king shark is coming back it's
going to be so awesome so what's going
to happen is I'll post that flash
trailer next I have a new spider-man
trailer to post there's new arrow
tomorrow there's a bunch of stuff so
I'll just update the video schedule when
I post new videos so just be sure to
check those out congratulations to Ethan
the boss you the latest flash ring
giveaway winner please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details there was a
new round in this video on ounce the
winner the next time I post a DC video
you can click here for that brand new
flash footage and click here for all my
guardians of the galaxy to Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you